in a group if you want to gain status  the way you do it is by sacrificing more  for the group than everyone else does if  you want to gain status in a company you  give more to the company than anyone  else does more than the company gives  you back because what do they do they  reward that behavior the group rewards  the person who gives to the group it's  how it works the people who take from  the group The only going to get status  end up getting banished by the group and  batted down because everyone wants to  keep that person down because they don't  serve anyone else and so it was only by  realizing that I had to give my life in  order to get it I had to serve because  when you serve someone you're giving  them status you're increasing your guard  for others when I gave status I got it  back and if you do that I promise you  you will have all the status you want